Oh
that the unified theory of autism
attempts to reconcile several
observations the first observation is
that siblings with autism is more common
than one would expect if each incidence
of autism was was random so if a child
is born has autism a brother is born the
chance that that brother has autism is
much higher than a male born to another
family and twins identical twins have an
extremely high concordance something
like 90% there is no other cognitive
disorder whose concordance among
identical twins is as high so those two
facts tell you that there's a genetic
component to autism however there are
families that have autistic children and
their large families and only one child
will have autism so the genetics would
look to be complicated there's inherited
component because siblings have a higher
rate of concurrence but there might also
be a sporadic component so the issue is
how to reconcile that I think that prior
to our serious involvement in the field
people assumed that there was what is
called a complex inherited model that
there are many genes that may be in the
wrong state and the parents which come
into some combination in the child so
the children of these parents have a
higher chance of having autism but it's
not a classical Mendelian pattern where
you know half of your kids have it or a
quarter of your kids have it half will
have it if it's the dominant 1/4 if it's
recessive the pattern seemed more
complicated in that what we did was come
in and say well you know it could be a
combination of both in some families it
is perhaps simple Mendelian
and another family's it's spontaneous
and if you assume that there are a large
number of genes that can give you autism
then you could have a very large
proportion of of autism being generated
by spontaneous mutation but if the
mutations don't all have complete what's
called complete penetrance that is you
can pass on the mutation to the child
could carry it and not show the disorder
then his or her children could then be
at risk in a Mendelian way of inheriting
that you so combining these two ideas
that the sibling risk is really a
combination of simple Mendelian in some
families with other families being
spontaneous mutation unifies these two
observations and does so in with a
coherent model so the coherent model is
that humans are mutating the rate of new
mutation giving rise to autism is
perhaps on the order of one and two
hundred kids and something like half of
those kids actually don't come down with
the diagnosis they mature they get
married they have children and those
children are then at risk from the
carriers now one of the very important
clues that is compatible with this model
is that the risk of autism is much
higher in boys than in girls if the
model almost any model is would predict
that whatever genetic abnormalities
exists in the boy those genetic
abnormalities will exist in a girl so
girls have something that makes them
resistant so girls in fact could be
natural carriers of genes that in a boy
would give the boy autism and that girl
might grow up in and and be healthy and
desirable mate and have children and her
her children in particular her male
offspring might be a high risk because
they might inherit the gene that she
safely carries that's the that's the
essence of the unified theory it does
not explain why autism
why boys are higher risk than girls
but it does suggest that you can have
two forms of an of genetic involvement
and inherited involvement from a carrier
parents and also those rare mutations
that destroy a gene in the germline I
should say and I really have to mention
this that in the model we're not saying
that only women are carriers in fact
there is a well-known example it's been
in the news of a male sperm donor who
had something on the order of 20 male
offspring and half of them had autism so
that's clearly a case where the sperm
donor who is I guess judged to be normal
probably maybe even brilliant or genius
was a carrier of a simple dominantly
inherited Mendelian trait
the incidence of autism
with the age of the parent and that's
entirely consistent with the new
mutation idea because it's already well
established in males that the number of
point mutations found in the male's
offspring go up with the age of the
father and there's also a correlation of
the age of the mother so there may be a
mild increase in the rate of autism in
those cultures where having children is
deferred and delayed the magnitude of
that effect is not going to explain the
overwhelming explosion in the number of
diagnoses but there may be a mild
increase in the rate of autism due to
that and the age dependence and on the
on the parents is consistent with the
new mutation hypothesis